hey everyone welcome to simply loans
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning about raspberry pi but
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you're a tech geek in
a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply
now without further ado let's get
started with the agenda for today's
tutorial
now we will get started with what is
raspberry pi where we will be explained
with the fundamentals of raspberry pi
and followed by that we will discuss
some of the critical differences between
the two best computers in the
semiconductor industry that has arduino
vs raspberry pi
next we will look into the mind-blowing
projects worked on raspberry pi in the
year 2022 and later on we will continue
with another version of the raspberry pi
that is raspberry pi zero and how to use
it and we will have an in-depth tutorial
on raspberry pi zero and finally we will
have a briefing about the latest version
of raspberry pi that is the raspberry pi
version 4.
we will understand what exactly is it
and the critical fundamentals of
raspberry pi 4.
now i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now let's get started with our
first topic that is what is raspberry pi
the raspberry pi foundation developed a
series of small single board computers
in the united kingdom so let's look at
today's agenda
we'll first discuss what is raspberry pi
then we will see some of the raspberry
pi use cases followed by which we will
see the different types of raspberry pi
boards available
proceeding further we will see the
applications of raspberry pi and lastly
we will see the advantages and
disadvantages of raspberry pi but before
we begin make sure you have subscribed
to our youtube channel and clicked on
the bell icon so you never miss an
update from simply learn
so without wasting any further time
let's get started with what is raspberry
pi
the raspberry pi is a small low-cost
computer the size of a credit card that
connects to a computer monitor or
television and utilizes a conventional
keyboard and mouse
raspberry pi can do everything a desktop
computer does including accessing the
internet
using raspberry pi we can watch high
definition videos access spreadsheets
word processing and play games
the raspberry pi can communicate with
the outside world and has been used in
variety of digital maker projects
raspberry pi is also used in music
machines and parent detectors as well as
weather stations and tweeting bird
houses with infrared cameras
raspberry pi use cases
raspberry pi is using computer desktop
a simple desktop can be built using a
raspberry pi a micro sd card and a power
source an hdmi cable and a suitable
display such as an old monitor are also
required you will also need a usb
keyboard and a mouse
robotics controller there are numerous
raspberry pi robot controller projects a
specific robotics package for pi is
available which is powered by the device
battery and can be used to interface
with and control robots
printing using a raspberry pi with the
raspberry pi we can print anything all
we need is raspberry pi that's connected
to your home network as well as some
print server software this is
accomplished by first installing the
samba file sharing program then cups
cup stands for common unix printing
system includes printer drivers as well
as management console
game server
the basic operating system for raspberry
pi has a special version of mini craft
game pre-installed the raspberry pi
applications can be used as a game
server it's fantastic minicraft game
server a wonderful gaming experience can
be created by using many raspberry pi
game machine
as a retro gaming machine the raspberry
pi is perfect it is one of the machine's
lightest components the raspberry pi
zero in particular is a variant that can
fit into small locations and be used for
gaming projects the raspberry pi may
also be used to restore many popular
16-bit game systems
now let us look at the types of
raspberry pi
the different types of raspberry pi are
raspberry pi model b
raspberry pi model a raspberry pi model
b plus raspberry pi model a plus
raspberry pi zero raspberry pi 2
raspberry pi 3 model b
and raspberry pi 0w
the different applications of raspberry
pi are it is used as media streamer
tablet computer
internet radio
home automation
robotics command
arcade devices
cosmic computer and different raspberry
pi projects
now let us look at the advantages of
raspberry pi
raspberry pi is about the size of a
credit card
the raspberry pi is inexpensive
using raspberry pi to function as a
server is more efficient than using a
regular server
the raspberry pi is ideal for adaptive
technology because it can display
visuals as well as play movies
the micro computer can be used by small
businesses on a tight budget to use
their product or build new technology
that integrates the product
now let us look at the disadvantages of
raspberry pi
raspberry pi is not a computer
replacement and the processor is not as
fast downloading and installing software
takes time
so you won't be able to do any intricate
multitasking
other operating systems such as windows
are incompatible
this product will not be beneficial for
large-scale businesses that already have
large servers which can perform all the
tasks that raspberry pi can
as a result it would not be worth it and
putting everything together it would
take time
in this video we will see arduino versus
raspberry pi
let us look at today's agenda we'll
first start with understanding what is
arduino
after that we will look at what is
raspberry pi
then we will see a comparison between
arduino versus raspberry pi on the
following parameters
control unit architecture
specifications
operating system licensing applications
and types of boards and at last we will
see which is better arduino or raspberry
pi
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon so you never
miss an update from simply learn so
without wasting any further time let's
get started
what is arduino
arduino is an open source electronic
gadget that reads inputs such as light
on a sensor a finger on a button or a
tweet and generates output based on
those inputs such as turning on the led
or activating a motor
arduino was created at a design
institute as a simple tool for students
with no prior experience with
electronics and programming
arduino boards are microcontrollers not
entire computers with operating systems
of their own like the raspberry pi
arduino just run c c plus plus code that
is stored in the firmware
the arduino ide integrated development
environment is free software that allows
you to create and upload code to an
arduino board
now let us see what is raspberry pi
raspberry pi is small low-cost computer
the size of a credit card that connects
to a computer monitor or television and
utilizes a conventional keyboard and a
mouse
raspberry pi can do everything a desktop
computer does including accessing the
internet
using raspberry pi we can watch high
definition videos access spreadsheets
word processing and play games
raspberry pi has a dedicated processor
memory and a graphics driver just like a
pc it also comes with its own operating
system raspberry pi operating system
which is a modified version of linux
raspberry pi is also used in music
machines parent detectors as well as
weather stations and tweeting bird
houses with infrared cameras
let us look at the comparison between
arduino versus raspberry pi first let us
look at the control unit
arduino is a member of atmega family of
microcontrollers
a microcontroller chip common on arduino
uno boats is atmega328
the 8-bit avr microcontroller family
includes atmega328 microcontrollers
a surface mount at mega chip is seen on
some arduino uno boards
the raspberry pi is an arm controller
unit
broadcom chips based on arm's cortex a
application processor have powered
raspberry pi from its release
the raspberry pi 3 is the latest version
of the raspberry pi launched in february
2016.
it has 1.2 gigahertz arm cortex a53 cpu
making it compatible for the arm 63.
it has 1.2 gigahertz arm cortex a53 cpu
making it compatible for the arm 64
architecture
architecture
the harvard architecture is used by
arduino cpu which means that the program
code and the program data have distinct
memory
it is made up of two types of memories
program memory and data memory
the data is saved in the data memory
while the code is kept in the flash
program memory
whereas in raspberry pi raspberry pi
contains a single core arm v6 processor
running at 700 megahertz
a video core force gpu and 512 mb of ram
its operating system and data are stored
on sd card
raspbian a lightweight linux operating
system based on debian is officially
supported by the raspberry pi
licensing
arduino is an open source electronics
platform that uses simple hardware and
software to make it easy to use
it's for everyone who wants to make
interactive projects
arduino perceives the environment by
receiving data from a variety of sensors
and actuators to influence its
surroundings
raspberry pi's hardware and software are
both proprietary raspberry pi has never
claimed to be open source
many aspects of it particularly the
software are open source but not all of
it is
the raspberry pi has been criticized for
having closed source components
operating system
arduino boards are single board
microcontrollers with firmware and no
operating system
a firmware program is a piece of
software that is installed on hardware
device
it doesn't have an operating system but
it does have a firmware which can be
programmed using several ides including
the arduino
ide raspberry pi operating system for pc
and mac is dbn with raspberry pi desktop
it installs the raspberry pi operating
system desktop on pc or apple mac as
well as most of the recommended software
that comes with raspberry pi operating
system
now let us look at the specifications
so we look at the specifications between
arduino uno r3 and raspberry pi 3 model
b plus
so if you look at the system arduino has
microcontroller system whereas raspberry
pi has single boarded computer processor
arduino has avr at mega 328p
and raspberry pi has broadcom
ram
in arduino uno we have ram of 2 kb
whereas in raspberry pi model 3 b plus
we have 1 gb ram
clock speed 16 megahertz in arduino and
1.4 gigahertz in raspberry pi
execution in arduino single program can
be executed at a time
whereas in raspberry pi multiple
programs can run at a time
current
current is 5 milli ampere in both
arduino and raspberry pi
and gpu io pins arduino has 20 and
raspberry pi has 40.
and power consumption in arduino is 175
milliwatt and in raspberry pi it is 700
milliwatt
applications
arduino is used in waving machines
traffic light countdown timer parking
lot counter embedded systems home
automation industrial automation medical
instrument and emergency light for
railways
whereas raspberry pi is used in desktop
pc wireless usage game servers retro
gaming machine robot controller stop
motion camera and time lapse camera
now let us look at the different types
of arduino and raspberry pi
in arduino we have arduino uno
lillipad arduino arduino mega arduino
leonardo
arduino red board and arduino shields
whereas in raspberry pi
we have raspberry pi one model b
raspberry pi one model a
model b plus model a plus
then we have raspberry pi 0 raspberry pi
2 raspberry pi 0w and raspberry pi 3
model p
and we know a raspberry pi which is
better the arduino and raspberry pi have
their own set of benefits and drawbacks
the best option for you will be
determined by the requirement of your
project and your budget
arduino is ideal for automating
repetitive operations such as opening
and closing doors turning on and off
lights and so on
arduino should be the first pick if your
project has any repeating elements and
just requires generating output
depending on sensory inputs
raspberry pi is ideally suited for
complex activities such as controlling
complex robots weather monitoring and
internet publishing among others if your
project necessitates advanced
functionality as well as internet access
then the raspberry pi is the option
in this video we will be discussing
about raspberry pi projects
the raspberry pi has a wide range of
uses
the microcomputer has grown to
accomplish many odd activities in
addition to many standard tasks
raspberry pi was created with the intent
of allowing people to play with the
circuit board and to aid in the
development of new computing skills
the internet is huge amount of
information about the raspberry pi's
various applications and projects
as well as recommendations on how to
execute them
we will go over a few projects that
demonstrate the microcomputer's wide
range of capabilities this video will
show you the most popular and useful
projects
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell like so you never
miss an update from simple
so without any further ado let's get
started
the first project is web server
the raspbian pi serves as a web server
for multiple users
there are numerous web server packages
to choose from however in the most
circumstances the raspberry pi's
performance is insufficient for reliably
hosting large amount of dynamic online
content
instead the mini computer is
significantly better suited for local
testing environment simple static
websites with low visitor accounts on
the other hand might be hosted on
raspberry pi server
scanner server
setting up your raspberry pi as a
scanner server using sane is a terrific
way to bring your old scanner up to date
instead of purchasing a wi-fi capable
scanner you can use a device like
raspberry pi zero to provide that
capabilities scanner access now easy is
the acronym for same this program serves
as a standardized method of gaining
access to the scanners
xbox cloud gaming on raspberry pi
microsoft's xbox cloud gaming service
allows you to stream various video games
from their servers to another device
in this project we will be streaming
these games from the xbox cloud gaming
service to the raspberry pi
using the chromium web browser you can
broadcast xbox cloud gaming to your
raspberry pi in a reasonably simple
manner
this project will even show you how to
turn your raspberry pi into pure xbox
cloud gaming machine
the xbox cloud gaming service isn't the
only game streaming option for your
raspberry pi you can also broadcast
games to use pi using google's gaming
service
game console
we can turn your raspberry pi into a
retro gaming console also we can now
simulate practically any classic game
from 1970s to the 1990s using this
little computer
retropie a piece of software that solves
all of your emulation needs is now
available it's simple piece of software
to set up and it also offers a
user-friendly interface
you may now play old games with retropie
you can use any raspberry pi model for
this project
however the raspberry pi 4 model such as
the raspberry pi model 4b that is 4gb is
strongly recommended
remote control 3d printer
octoprint which is one of the most well
known 3d printing program can also be
used on raspberry pi this software lets
you collect statistics and even monitor
your 3d printer from afar
this software lets you collect
statistics and even monitor your 3d
printer from afar
you can now control your 3d printer
remotely rather than using an sd card
aside from that you can connect a webcam
to a 3d printer to monitor the progress
of your printing
you will need a wi-fi adapter like the
model tl
wn725n to make your 3d printer work
because you will need to connect it to
the internet
language translator
this project necessitates some coding
and programming experience
we can utilize the google translate
library or any other python translating
tool to make this project much easier
you will need to know how to set up text
to speech speech recognition translation
apis and so on because this project has
many layers
overall it's still a worthwhile project
that you can do with your raspberry pi
and add to your achievements of
raspberry pi projects
security camera
you may have observed that different
raspberry pi models are compatible with
different camera modules
the raspberry pi 8 megapixel camera
module for example is only compatible
with raspberry pi 1 2 and 3 versions
you may now make your own security
camera for your home with this camera
model another advantage of this project
is that you can add whatever other
features you like
for example we can access video feeds
from afar and have them immediately
uploaded to a server for backup
a number of package or library
prerequisites are already available on
the internet on your raspberry pi you
can simply download or alter it
wi-fi extender
a wi-fi extender is another simple
project it's a low cost and effective
solution to increase wifi range
if you have a bad wifi signal in your
garden or even your room you may utilize
your raspberry pi to boost your signal
it's an excellent substitute for
commercial wi-fi repeater furthermore
because this is a diy project you can
always alter it and add new features
because this job has already been
completed by many people you can just
search the internet for the finest and
most convenient way to complete it
running android tv on raspberry pi
android tv is specialized version of
google's famous mobile operating system
it has a revised interface that better
accommodates the horizontal nature of
television screens
because the operating system is better
suited to wide horizontal screens and
remote controls it's the best option for
connecting the pi to your tv the google
play store also gives you access to many
downloadable apps
the most significant difficulty with
running android tv on the raspberry pi
right now is that builds lack hardware
video decoding and encoding capabilities
the pi 4 mod will be pi 400 and the
compute model 4 are the only devices
that can run android tv
running zoom on the raspberry pi
we can utilize the feature to set up
meetings so that people can readily
connect with you
the individual hosting the meeting on
the other hand will need their own zoom
account
the person who creates a meeting has the
authority to determine who is allowed to
speak and share resources such as the
computer screen
with the free plan you can connect up to
100 additional individuals for total of
40 minutes because the raspberry pi does
not contain any arm binaries it is
difficult to run zoom on it
we will use a handy piece of software
called box 86 to get around this
box 86 is an emulation program that
transforms 86 instructions to arm
instruction set which the raspberry pi
recognizes
raspberry pi bluetooth speakers
you may greatly expand the capabilities
of your raspberry pi by connecting it to
a set of speakers
this project gives you the opportunity
to stream audio directly to any vintage
speakers or hifi system making them more
modern
we can add support for apple airplay
spotify connect and synchronize multiple
room audio to raspberry pi in addition
to bluetooth audio
we are going to utilize a balina image
named balinas sound to bring all of this
extra capabilities to our raspberry pi
this instruction from balina greatly
simplifies the setup process and should
lessen the chances of making mistakes
home assistant using raspberry pi
home assistant is an open source home
automation program that was created
using raspberry pi based device the
software was created with the goal of
protecting your privacy and retaining
control in the hands of the user
you can monitor the status of all of
your devices in your house with the home
assistant you can even automate your
interactions with them
we can program home assistant to turn on
all of the lights automatically when it
gets dark and you're at home when you
cast a movie on your chromecast you can
even program it to dim the lights in
your giving room
raspberry pi is an excellent platform
for home automation its compact
inexpensive has many networking
functions and consumes little power
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
minecraft using raspberry pi
for this project we need to install a
custom version of minecraft designed
just for raspberry pi minecraft pi
edition is the name of this version of
minecraft
this version of minecraft is much older
than the current version it does however
have an advantage it is entirely free
additionally this version of minecraft
includes a python library for
interacting with the game environment
in this video we will discuss about a
particular type of raspberry pi that is
raspberry pi zero see what's in it for
you in this session
we'll first start with understanding
what is raspberry pi
followed by we will see some of the
features of raspberry pi 0 and
specifications of raspberry pi 0.
then we will see applications
and the difference between raspberry pi
0 and raspberry pi 0w
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
click down the bell icon so you never
miss an update from simply learn
the raspberry pi zero
the raspberry pi zero is a super cheap
super compact computer the zero is
smaller than a credit card measuring 65
millimeter by 30 millimeter and is only
five millimeter thick
it also weights nine grams the raspberry
pi zero is inexpensive costing only four
to five dollars
the raspberry pi zero w is member of the
pi zero family with wireless lan and
bluetooth capabilities
the raspberry pi zero uses the same
single core broadcom cpu as the original
raspberry pi however it has been turned
to one gigahertz making it 40 faster
than the original
when you consider the zero raspberry pi
with 502 mb of ram it's around three
times faster than the original raspberry
pi in terms of total performance
features of raspberry pi zero
the raspberry pi zero has a single tiny
hdmi port rather than the full hdmi port
found on prior raspberry pi devices
despite this it can still produce video
at
1080p and 60 frames per second
one micro usb port provides power to the
raspberry pi 0 while the other serves as
the usb outboard for connecting a
keyboard mouse wi-fi dongle or other
peripheral
there is no standard wi-fi or ethernet
port on the raspberry pi zero you will
have to figure out how to connect to the
internet on your own
but that's the kind of purpose of this
bare bones gadget
it has an unpopulated 40-pin gpio header
and an unpopulated composite video
header just as all other raspberry pi
variants you can use this to solder on
your own interface components if you
like
which is where the raspberry pi's
enormous potential and flexibility
really shine
another important cost cutting technique
is the lack of fixed storage on
raspberry pi zero instead you will need
to provide your own storage in the form
of micro sd card which you may place
into the provided slot
the raspberry pi zero like previous
raspberry pi devices runs on raspbian
its lightweight operating system based
on the debian operating system open
source project
being free to download raspberry and
also gives users access to pi shop which
is essentially an app store with
hundreds of packages built particularly
for the raspberry pi given the raspberry
pi zeros capable hardware it can just
run about any packages
now let us look at the applications of
raspberry pi the raspberry pi 0 is
already a computer that can be used as a
desktop pc or notebook without the need
for a screen or keyboard some of the
applications are it is used to make a
wildlife camera
this is the droid you are looking for
build a portable pocket sized computer
a compact raspberry pi zero server
binary clock with unique unicorn p hat
zerobot raspberry pi zero fpv robot
remote control smart drone
raspberry pi zero wi-fi security camera
portable game console
home network music system google home
with bluetooth speaker and many more
specifications of raspberry pi 0.
some of the specifications of raspberry
pi 0 are it has
point one one
with less lag
bluetooth of four point one bluetooth
low energy and one gigahertz single core
cpu five two lmb of ram
mini hdmi port and micro usb otg port
micro usb power
hat compatible 40 pin header composite
video and reset headers and csi camera
connectors
now let us look at the difference
between raspberry pi 0 and raspberry pi
0w
the w in raspberry pi 0
stands for wireless and it denotes the
pi 0 model's wireless functionality that
is the most significant distinction
between the two models while the
raspberry pi 0 was designed to deliver
more functionality while being half the
size of a plus board
later the raspberry pi 0w was released
with built-in wireless connectivity
eliminating the need for a separate
accessory or module to enable bluetooth
and wi-fi
the raspberry pi zero is five dollars
whereas the raspberry pi zero w is
roughly ten dollars the price will of
course vary depending on its
availability and location the main
distinction between two is this with the
rest of specification staying the same
in this video we will discuss about
raspberry pi 4.
let's see what's in it for you in
today's session
we'll first start with understanding
what is raspberry pi 4
then we will look at some of its
features
and specifications and lastly we will
see the applications of raspberry pi 4
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell like so you never
miss an update from simply love
what is raspberry pi 4
the raspberry pi 4 model b which is a
1.5 gigahertz 64-bit quad-core arm
cortex a72 processor which was released
in june 2019
when utilized with an adequate power
supply the pi 4 can be also be powered
using a usb c connector allowing for
more power to be delivered to downstream
peripherals
raspberry pi 4 can do everything a
desktop computer does including
accessing the internet and watching high
definition videos as well as
spreadsheets word processing and game
the raspberry pi 4 is capable of
handling a wide range of tasks including
reading articles like watching videos
and working with the text
features of raspberry pi 4.
raspberry pi 4 has improved speed and
performance over previous generations we
have created a complete desktop
experience for the first time whether
you are editing documents browsing the
web with multiple tab opens wrangling
spreadsheets or creating a presentation
the experience will be smooth and
familiar
multiple usb ports the usb ports on your
raspberry pi 4 has been upgraded in
addition to the two usb connection there
are
two usb 3 ports which can transport data
up to 10 times quicker
quick networking
gigabit ethernet interconnected wireless
networking and bluetooth are included
with the raspberry pi 4.
silent and energy saving the raspberry
pi is fanless energy efficient computer
that works quietly and consumes
significantly less electricity than
traditional pcs
ram selection depending on how much ram
you need raspberry pi offers multiple
variants
1gb 2gb 4gb and 8gb ram
now let us look at the specifications of
raspberry pi 4.
raspberry pi has broadcom quad-core
cortex is 72 arm version 864-bit
processor
it has 1gb 2gb 4gb or 8gb sd ram
it has 2.4 gigahertz and 5.0 gigahertz
ieee wireless bluetooth of 5.0
it has gigabit ethernet two usb 3.0
ports and two usb 2.0 ports raspberry pi
standard 40 pin gpio header
two micro hdmi ports
two lan mipi dsi display port
two lan csi camera port
4 pole stereo audio and composite video
port
micro sd slot for loading os and data
student
5 volt dc usb c connector and 5 volt dc
gpio header
and power over ethernet is enabled and
lastly operating temperature is between
0 to 50 degrees celsius
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now let us look at some of the
applications of raspberry pi 4.
raspberry pi 4 is used for portable gape
console
home network music system
google home with bluetooth speaker
raspberry pi food security system
social media bot using raspberry pi 4.
then we have raspberry pi based retro
gaming system
machine learning on raspberry pi 4
raspberry pi 4 wi-fi security camera
remote control smart drone portable
pocket size computer
now with that we have come to an end of
this session on raspberry pi if you have
any queries regarding any of the topics
covered in the session or if you require
the resources that we used in this
session then please feel free to let us
know in the comment section below and
our team of experts will be more than
happy to resolve all your queries after
your list until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you